yeah thank you very very much so uh
what i like to do is i'd like to start
out
by telling you who i am and why i'm here
so our diploma thesis a master's thesis
before
some of you were born and
i used the classical invariants
so-called brackets
for carrying out some very concrete
computations with metroids and
and convex polytopes and i had read as a
student that according to felix klein's
elenor pogam
which you was just mentioned in the
previous talk
that geometry is in their influence
according to client the definition
of geometry it's those properties of the
coordinates
that are left in there under appropriate
transformations and i was very inspired
by that
then i met rota
who had a huge influence on me so i was
a post-doc
at the ima in minneapolis one of the
math institutes that existed long before
this computer science institute and
it was fantastic to be there as a
postdoc i'm sure some of the postdocs
here feel the same about the simons
and one day dennis stanton came to me
and says you've been selected as the
note taker you know you've been
volunteered to be the notetaker for
professor rota
so professor rota gave two lectures
called introduction
to invariant theory in super algebras
anyway that led to a joint paper so i
have a joint paper with rota with this
title that nobody has ever read
now in the following year in my second
post
postdoc
i was in in linz austria
and actually i offered a course so i was
really i thought now i really should
learn more about invariant theories or
offer the one semester course
called algorithms and invariant theory
and that was later published as a book
in the risk series
risk is the research institute for
symbolic computation founded by bruno
buchberger
and that's another advice to the postdoc
there is no better time in your life to
write a book
than as a poster
now my first regular job at cornell in
the first year there was a program at
another institute that's been
scaled down quite a bit since dimax by
some measure was the first
theoretical computer science institute
and they ran their first program on
computational geometry
and that's where i met kitan so both
kitan and i have a background
in computational geometry and then you
know we sort of
did other things since and now we met
again so that's the brief
personal history so what's invariant
theory is let's fix a field
k of characteristic zero so such as the
real
or complex numbers i'm going to consider
a matrix group g
so g is a subgroup of the group
gln of invertible n by n matrices so g
is not just an abstract group
but it's given as a group of n by n
matrices
now every matrix little g
in the group gives us a linear change of
coordinates
on the ambient vector space k to the n
and it also transforms polynomials so
the notation here is k
x 1 up to x n is the ring of polynomials
and
n variables x 1 up to x n with
coefficients and k
and you know this here's the rule for
changing coordinates
so every invertible matrix transforms a
polynomial to a new polynomial
the variant of g is a polynomial that's
left unj
unchanged by this transformation for
every group element
so if for every group element little g
in the group the image of
a given polynomial under this
transformation is the same polynomial
then i call that polynomial an invariant
now if you have two invariant
polynomials you can add them
and get another invariant you can
multiply them get another invariant
and multiply by scalars and so on so
they form a sub ring
they form a sub k algebra and this is my
notation
k x 1 up to x n upper g this is the set
or sub ring of invariance this is the
invariant ring so this is the
sub ring sub algebra we're going to be
interested in
now everybody is familiar with one
example of this which is the ring of
symmetric polynomials
so in this case s n is the group
of n by n permutation matrices
that's a group of order n factorial
these are the permutation matrices and
for example so we know that this is
generated
by the elementary symmetric polynomials
since k is characteristic zero it's also
generated by the power
sums and concrete examples so here we
have the polynomial ring in three
variables
and the invariant polynomials are
generated as a k
algebra by either the elementary
symmetric polynomials
or the power sum so if any other
invariant polynomial
walks into the door along
with professor christandl walks into the
door then we can write this as a
polynomial in the elementary symmetric
polynomials
and that representation and this example
happens to be unique
but in general the representation may
not be unique
let's do another example let's take g to
be the
group of two by two matrices given in
this set
so this is the set of these four two by
two matrices so as an abstract group
this would be the cyclic group of order
four
but we are thinking about this as a
group of matrices
well what are the invariants well the
first thing you notice so i defined
an invariant to be a polynomial that's
fixed by
any group element but it suffices to
look at generators of the group
right so if you have generators of the
group if some polynomial is fixed by the
generators then it will be fixed by
every group element so
this group is generated by a single
matrix for example this one so the
invariant ring consists of all
polynomials and two unknowns
such that if i replace y by x
sorry and i replace x by negative y i
get the same polynomial so here are
three polynomials
that have this property x squared plus y
squared then
and two of degree four x squared y
squared and then here more interesting
one
x cubed y minus x y cubed is also an
invariant
now i claim that these generate the ring
of invariance again
if any other invariant walks into the
door we can write it
as a polynomial in the three basic
invariants
but that representation is not unique in
fact there's a relation there's an
algebraic relation among
these three invariants so modulo that
algebraic relation
it would be unique so a is the quadratic
and b
and c are the cubics so if i think of a
as an unknown of degree 2 and b and c
is an unknown of degree 4 there's this
relation of degree 8
and uh so the ring of invariance in this
case
is a polynomial ring and a b and c
modulo the principle ideal generated
by that relation they are isomorphic
missing or is that double slash uh
double slash a quotient or git quotient
yes we could do a single slash
okay good i'm not missing anything um so
how should we think about the ring of
adventure why do we look at these rings
at all well they are the ring of
functions the ring of polynomial
functions on some space
and the space is the quotient so in this
example
if we look at k2 and we make a new
space we can make a new variety by
lumping together
everything in an orbit where in this
example all
orbits but one have four elements and
you know there's just the origin has a
lonely guy in the orbit
and then the orbits are parametrized
exactly by solutions to this equation
in this example okay
now the question i'd like to address
first is how can we be sure that there
are no other invariants you certainly
agree
that these three things are invariant
you easily check
that they satisfy this as the generating
relation
but maybe there's some other invariant
out there that's not yet
represented by these three how can we
really be sure that these are all the
invariants
here's one more example where i'm using
a group that's
not a finite group but an infinite group
so here i'm gonna sort of shift gears a
little bit so let's look at k
star the multiplicative group of the
field k
as an abstract group okay
so i'm going to take that abstract group
k star and i represent it
by three by three diagonal matrices
and that gives me a three by three
matrix group and i'm going to write this
by telling you what it how it acts on
polynomials so
t is a non-zero scalar and then the
action is well you scale x by t squared
y by t cubed and z by one over t to the
seven
right so that's an action that's a given
you
explicitly you know infinite set
of three by three matrices that as a
matrix group is
isomorphic to the abstract group k star
and i'm interested
which polynomials are left in variant
under this
action well for monomials it's sort of
easy right so this is
as a vector space it's generated by
monomials that are invariant right this
acts diagonally
so uh as a k vector space i have to look
at monomials
x to the i y to the j z to the k
such that 2i plus g 3j is
7k and again you know you can calculate
the finite list in this case there are
four
monomials listed here you quickly see
that these are invariant and i claim
that they generate the ring
every other invariant will be a
polynomial with coefficients and k
in those now
is it true that the ring of invariance
or
s short for the polynomial ring so is it
true that the ring of invariance is
always finally generated
that's a basic question so we'll answer
this question today
well for example if we have such a
scaling action
well then the problem boils down to
calculating to solving a linear system
of equations
over the non-negative integers but it
turns out that the semi-group or monoid
of non-negative integer solutions to a
linear system of equations
is always finally generated so if g is
an algebraic taurus
the answer is yes so every semi-group
in this case we're looking at l as a
linear subspace
namely the plane given by this equation
we're taking this linear subspace and
we're looking at non-negative integer
points on it and that's finally
generated as a semi group
and there's very fast software called
normales
they will calculate this for you okay so
if you're given a linear subspace l
you can calculate this finite set the
so-called hilbert basis quite rapidly
now the answer to the blue question is
also yes if g
is a finite group so if g is a finite
group of
n by n matrices then the answer is also
yes
and i'm going to prove that to you in a
moment
let's talk a little bit about finite
matrix groups
so one thing that you can do with the
finite matrix group is you can take the
average over the orbit of a polynomial
so if p
is a polynomial i'm going to write p
star
for the average of all elements of all
transformed polynomials in the orbit so
i take
1 over the order of the group and then g
of p
is the transformed polynomial and this
is a finite sum
it's legit to divide by the order of g
because the characteristic is zero okay
so in this talk three is never zero
so therefore this is well defined so i
get a map
from s to the ring of invariance from
all so i take a map
takes any polynomial in s and makes an
invariant in sg
and that's called the reynolds operator
well what happened so the world expert
on this topic happens to be in the
audience gregor where are you
there's griego okay so so i wrote a
really really so here's the thing your
talk you write a book chances are it's
pretty bad okay
but the good thing is that experts like
professor popov and others look at it
give you feedback and eventually a
couple years later somebody will write a
real good book so the good book was
written by daxton campo
and gregor in particular is an expert on
finite characteristics so maybe i'll
differ
well there's certainly no reynolds
operator and things do go wrong the
finer generation still is true
but the calculation is harder and the
structural properties are much
worse so everything that may be fast
does happen in the case of the
characteristic device
okay now the reynold operator which we
have
under my hypotheses has the following
three properties
a it's a k linear map right so if you
take a
just a linear combination right so the
average of two polynomial if you take
the
sum of two polynomials then the average
is the sum of the averages
right that's clear first of all if you
start already with an invariant
polynomial and you average you get that
same polynomial back right so on
the sub ring of invariance on the sub
ring of invariance
the reynolds operator is the identity
the average of an invariant is that
invariant
and the last property c is the following
it's an
sg module homomorphism so in english
if p happens to be an invariant
and you multiply it with a non-invariant
g
and then you average well you could do
it the other way around you could first
do the average and then do the
multiplication okay so that's the
the last property so if p is invariant q
is anything
then the star of their product is p
times q star
okay so so that's equivalent to saying
that that the reynolds operator is a
modular homomorphism
over the invariant ring
oops now it could happen
right it might happen that for some
group g that's not a finite group
right some other matrix group might have
this property too so let's introduce an
adjective so
i'm going to say a group of n by n
matrices is reductive
if such an operator exists right so we
have some infinite group
maybe but it could happen that there's
some operator star that satisfies a b
and c i'm going to call that a reductive
group
and then you know finite matrix groups
and characteristics 0 are reductive
that's the remark which is
so here's hilbert's theorem so in 1890
hilbot proved that the invariant ring of
a reductive
matrix group is finally generated
and i would like to give you the proof i
will give you the proof
okay so if you have a group of matrices
and that include that's reductive so
this includes all finite groups and
some infinite groups and if we have
these properties a b
and c then the ring is finally generated
well we have to you know use these three
properties
so let's remember them right so this is
a talk for the students so remember a b
and c
we're going to use all three okay yes
doesn't number three implied c both b
and a
just one room um
well maybe a uh yeah maybe but let me
list them
separately good somebody's paying
attention
okay here's the unique proof in this
talk
okay so let's go through the proof so
well first of all
the invariant ring is a k vector space
right that's clear
it's a vector space over k and it's
spanned by the symmetrization of all
monomials
right so the polynomial ring as a vector
space
has a basis namely the monomials and
so if i you know every polynomial is a
linear combination of monomials
but by property a you know i can apply
the star so therefore
sg is a k vector space is spanned by
symmetrizations
reynoldsizations of monomials
now among all of these infinitely many
monomials there's one that's special i'm
going to kick
out that's one okay so i'm removing you
know the monomial one so i look at all
the
non-constant monomials and i write i
g for the ideal in s that's generated by
these
so ig is the ideal generated by all
non-constant symmetrized monomials or
equivalently ig
is the ideal generated by
all homogeneous invariants of positive
degree
now pi hilbert's basis theorem proved in
that very same paper for that very
purpose
by hilbert's basis theorem the ideal ig
is finally generated in fact it's
finally generated by a finite subset of
the set i gave you
right so i've given you an idea in terms
of an infinite generating set
then this infinite generating set has a
finite subset that generates the same
ideal
okay that's the basis there proved in
the same paper
so the ideal is generated by a finite
set of invariants and i'm going to call
these invariants p1
p2 up to pm
now i claim that we're done okay so i
claim that these
same invariants generate the ring
of invariance as a k algebra
that's the set we want okay that was
hilbert's argument so
well let's prove it so we do what we
teach our freshman discrete math
students we proceed by
contradiction right suppose not okay
so suppose not and pick a counter
example so pick a counter example for
example of minimal degree so
i'm assuming that these guys they're
certainly you know these are all
invariants so whatever this ring is it's
contained in the ring of invariance
but it may not be the whole thing so
maybe out there there's some other
invariant q
and then you know the positive integers
are well ordered or something right so
there exists one of smallest degree
q
okay well q is certainly in the ideal ig
right so id
ig is the ideal of all homogeneous
invariants of positive degrees so q is
in there
and since p1 up to pm generate this
ideal we can write q
as a linear combination f1 plus p1
blah blah blah plus f1 times pm
where the fi are some polynomials
now furthermore by looking at the degree
we can assume
that these multipliers f i are
homogeneous of complementary degree
so the f's and q have strictly positive
degree
and then you know the multipliers f i
can be chosen of complementary degree so
f2
can be chosen of the s as degree
whatever the degree of q
is minus the degree of p2
so now we're going to apply properties b
and c and as yes go pointed out it's
really all probability c
right so now we're going to apply the
other properties so so this invariant q
is equal to q star because it's an
invariant now we're going to plug in we
use the property c
so it's f star times p1 blah blah blah
up to fm star times pm
what does this say well now i've written
q as a linear combination of the same
generators but
now the multipliers are in variance of
positive degree
so therefore each f i star
so each fi star now is an invariant but
its degree is strictly less than the
degree of q
and we're done right so that's a
contradiction right by the minimality
assumption here
up there each fi star is already in the
sub ring generated by p1 up to pm
and that contradiction proves the
theorem okay
so that's it that was hilbert's argument
and as katan said some people thought
this was
theology
the theology is here right the theology
is in the basis there so how
you know how are you going to make these
generators how how do you find the
generators right from some
if you're given the matrix group how do
you actually do this so we'll talk about
this in a moment
okay so that's hilbert's theorem but
before we go on you know let's
make a few more comments about finite
groups that make this more precise so
so eminerto in 1916 um
gave a degree bound actually she showed
that for finite group
again under my hypotheses all you need
to have to look at is the polynomials of
degree at most the group order right so
the ring of invariance
is generated by polynomials of at most
the group order
and then in particular that would also
give you finite generation that's a
separate argument that she gave
and we've seen already one example where
this bound is tight right so the
group of rotations by 90 degrees so
we rotate by 90 degrees that's a group
of order four
we had two minimal generators of degree
four so
so this is tight in general here's
another one that i like a lot so this
is uh moline's theorem from 1897
so so one reason i can't talk to the
experts
in the room in this tutorial because
most of them are dead
so moline in 1897
calculate the hilbert series of the ring
of invariance
right so what's the hilbert series so by
definition
you can make a generating function in an
unknown z
where you know you sum up z to the d and
the coefficient of z to the d
is the k vector space dimension of the d
graded component so this is the vector
space of
invariance homogeneous of degree d so
finite dimensional vector space
and we just record its dimension these
dimensions in a generating function
and this is well known to be a rational
function in z
but moline gave an explicit formula
namely it's the average of the inverted
characteristic polynomials of all group
elements and what i'm going to do in my
characteristic polynomial you know
usually you write matrix
minus z times the identity but i'm going
to switch the z okay so
slightly modified characteristic point
on me so i look at any matrix in the
group
i look at this modified characteristic
polynomial so the identity matrix minus
z
times that matrix one over it is a
rational function and then i take the
average of these rational functions
that's a rational function and according
to moline this is the hillbot series
okay that's a very useful trick
because it allows you to calculate the
sort of the enumerative properties the
the hilbert series ahead of time without
actually calculating invariance
so let's look at this in my example so
if my group is
generated by rotation by 90 degrees
right so then here
i have these four characteristic
polynomials so this bar
just means the determinant of this
matrix then i take
the reciprocal i add it up right and
then you know i get this
rational function that has this very
suggestive form 1 minus c to the eight
divided by a product of three things and
you know experts in this game they will
suspect you know uh that uh
maybe i got this maybe there's a typo
anyway so by looking at this you can
suspect
you know what the degrees of the
generators and
and the abc relation might be klim do
you know how to calculate
materials for polar reductive groups
well in this slide we're doing it for
finite groups
well let's get there okay so here i gave
a formula
of course if g is a big group right then
you can ask the question how to evaluate
the sum rapidly
so let's do the sum here for a moment
anyway
so then you know i get this generating
function so this says
there are three linearly independent
invariants in degree six
but there are no invariants in degree
five for example
okay so we know that ahead of time and
that can guide the calculation
i'm going to give you two algorithms so
the first one i'm going to call the
crude algorithm
okay for calculating the invariance of
the invariant ring of a finite group
okay
so step one calculate the moline series
right so
ah sum over all matrices in the group
and average the inverted characteristic
polynomial so now we know the hilbert
series
as a rational function then you make a
bunch of invariants of low degree
using you know the reynolds operator
right you list your
37 you know first monomials you like you
take average and you have a bunch of
events some often you'll get zero right
often you get duplicates but you just
make a bunch of invariants
well then you calculate the hilbert
series of the current
sub-algebra so you have a bag of
invariants in your hand
using implicitization grouping bases
bertini whatever you can calculate the
hilbert series of
that sub algebra right that's a rational
function
but it's the algebra generated by the
invariance you now have
okay well it might happen that you're
very
very lucky namely it might happen that
that rational function
equals to the other precomputed rational
function as
rational functions well if that happens
we're done well why is that well
both the invariant ring and the current
sub ring
are graded k algebras particular they're
graded k vector spaces where each graded
component has a finite dimension
right now we're using the following
principle
if you have a finite dimensional vector
space
contained in another finite dimensional
vector space
and if those two vector spaces have the
same dimension
then they the same vector space okay
people are smiling right but that's an
important fact
so based on that we're done okay now if
you're not done you go back and make
more invariance
okay so that's the crude algorithm if
you have a degree bound that's an actual
algorithm and otherwise it's a heuristic
now let me give you another algorithm
that was invented by harm darksen in
1999 but it should have really been
invented by you know gordon and hilbot
and it goes like this you introduce
three sets of variables so the input to
the algorithm is
a matrix group maybe a finite group of n
by n matrices
and i'm going to introduce three sets of
variables first of all the n
x variables n is the dimension of the
space
the n y variables and then i'm going to
also
make variables for the group right so
the group is a finite group
it's going to be infinite in a moment
but it's a finite group so it's a finite
subset
in the space of n by n matrices so in
particular it's a variety
right so every finite subset of the n
squared
dimensional vector space over k so i'm
going to write down
equations i'm going to cut out my group
elements by
a bunch of equations g 1 up to g r and
n squared unknowns
okay um i'm sorry g
is so i'm writing g for the coordinates
and then you know
the equations i'm gonna just call this
so g
and g this ideal is the equations that
cut out the group
okay okay now i'm gonna do the following
and look at the following ideals so look
at the
n-coordinates of y minus gx
right so let g act on x the vector x
and i wanna say it's equal to y right so
this is
n polynomials i throw in the equation of
the group so this is an ideal j
in a polynomial ring and two n plus r
unknowns
and i've given you generators
now i'm going to eliminate the group g
so i you know for example put a
lexiographic term order that makes
g1 up to gr very expensive
and the x is cheap and desirable and
then you calculate the elimination idea
so i take this ideal and i intersect it
with the
sub ring generated by the x's and the
y's
so now i have a bunch of polynomial and
x's and y's
and i'm going to get rid of the y's i
just set y 1 up to y
n zero so now i have a bunch of
polynomial in the x's
a little confused what these g's are
okay so
is a vector no it's a vector i'm sorry
so g represents a group
element so for example you know
i could take r to be n squared right so
i just make
one unknown for every entry in my matrix
and then this is you know whatever
equations i have
so this is just the ideal of the
algebraic group
which in this case is a finite group
okay
well now and then i have p1 i just
averaged them and they generate
okay so according to darkson the
averages
p1 star up to pm star i'm sorry will
generate the ring of invariance
okay so let's see a small example just a
practical example so we had the taurus
action
so we acted on three-dimensional space
so what's the role of this in in
geometry what we're saying we're looking
at triples right
of two points in the space of a point
and another point and a group element
that moves it
that moves from one to the other right
so in particular this ideal this
parenthesis
ideal is the variety represents the
variety of pairs of points that are in
the same orbit
okay and then i eliminate y so here's a
small example so my group is
the taurus k star i'm introducing you
know this
characterizes this group so i'm
introducing two variables
s and t and the equation s times t
minus one right so that describes k
star as an affine variety and
as a group as an algebraic group right
so and then
you know i have this part over here this
is n equals 3 equations so u
minus t squared x v minus t
cubed y w minus
s to the seventh z right s is the
inverse of t
and now you get your device and you say
grappler right and you do this
and you get the generators we had on
this couple slides ago okay
okay now what about classical invariant
theory of course hilbert was interested
in finite groups
but it was even more interested in the
general linear group and the special
linear group
and those are the kind of groups that we
heard in the previous talk
and we'll hear much more about this week
and the rest of the semester
and that was the group that was on your
mind
but of course now we need maybe a moment
to talk about
representation so what i said so far is
we're taking groups of
n by n matrices and i'm continuing in
the rest of this talk
i will continue to look at matrix groups
so i'm going to write d for the sld so
sld
is the special linear group these are d
by d
matrices with determinant one
that's an abstract group so i think
about this as an
abstract group so i take the abstract
group
sld and i represent it as a matrix group
acting on a big space an n-dimensional
space
and the map row that does the
representation
will be assumed to be a polynomial
representation
okay so rho is a polynomial function
that maps d by d matrices and makes
n by n matrices and
in this example it's actually equivalent
to assume they're rational functions
okay but
let me assume they're polynomial
functions so rho the representation
is given to you by n squared
polynomials in d squared unknowns
very soon okay so rho is given to you by
n squared polynomials and d squared
unknowns
now the fact that klim was asking about
is is this group reductive yes this
group is reductive so for this group
there is
a reynolds operator and it's actually
interesting so what is the reynolds
operator how do you realize it how do
you average over this group
and there are different strategies for
doing this so there's sort of
maybe three different ways of of doing
this
the classical way you know attributed to
cayley is something called
the cayley's omega process so kaylee's
omega process is a sort of a
differential operator
that carries out the averaging for you
okay well if you're more into calculus
you can take the sum
that i had in the definition of the
reynolds operator and think of it as a
riemann sum and turn it into an integral
right so somehow we want to
into rather than summing over this group
we want to integrate over this group
well that doesn't quite work right so we
have to pass to a compact subgroup so
integrating over the appropriate compact
subgroup
is another instantiation of the reynolds
operator and then more
so there are three or four different
ways of carrying out the reynolds
operator
let's do an example let me take
d to be two and n
to be four so
the abstract group i'm talking about is
the group
of two by two matrices with determinant
one
okay which i think of as a hyper surface
in a four dimensional space right so in
four dimensional space with coordinates
x one one x one two x two 1 x 2
2 i have a hyper surface given by saying
this times this minus that times that is
1
and that's a group that's an abstract
group called sl2
now i'm representing this abstract group
in a four dimensional vector space so
now
i have a four by four matrix
and my map row is given
by this formula and the particular one
thing situation
that this describes is the adjoined
representation
so x is a two by two
matrix so i'm acting with the abstract
group
sl2 on the concrete vector space
of all two by two matrices and the
action is conjugation
so the action is you take a invertible
two by two matrix with determinant one
and it acts on a 2 by 2 matrix by this
formula
now this doesn't look like a polynomial
you know
representation but you can replace g
inverse
by the adjoint or adject right so you
can replace this by
the adjoin and then this becomes a
polynomial
representation given by a quadratic
16 quadratic monomials
in four unknowns g11 g12 g21 g22
that is the representation okay
now another way of saying this the
vectorization
of this two by two matrix so this two by
two matrix is a point
in a four-dimensional space so if you
write its coordinate as a vector of
length four
column vector of length four then you
get that column vector of length four
by letting multiplying this four by four
matrix
on the right with the column vector x 1
1
x 1 2 x 2 1 x 2 2.
is that clear students and post docs is
that clear that's how the representation
works it eats
an invertible two by two matrix and it
represents it
by this formula as a four by four matrix
that's my matrix group so my matrix
group
is the group of all four by four
matrices that look like this
okay now what is the invariant ring in
this case for the joint representation
or what
functions are invariant right
well in this case it's uh not so
difficult so
what functions of a two by two matrix
are left in variant under conjugation
well for example the determinant right
so the determinant is a polynomial in
the axis
and since g by definition has
determinant one
right the determinant of x is an
invariant
another invariant is the trace and they
generate
so in this example the ring of
invariance is generated by a linear
polynomial
namely the trace and the quadratic
polynomial
namely the determinant
now orbits play a big role
in this workshop so i should say a few
words about orbits
so in the finite group case we saw that
the ring of invariance the
is exactly the coordinate ring on some
variety and the point of that
the points of that variety were exactly
the orbits
that gets more complicated quite a bit
more complicated for
infinite groups so let's you know
look at this example so first of all
it's clear that the air and variants
are constant along orbits and they're
closures right so the invariants are
polynomials
and by definition you know along each
orbit
an invariant will be take constant
values
and since everything is you know these
are polynomials so it has same
values still everywhere in the limit so
these are going to be
constant and orbit closures
now maybe all the orbits are closed
right in the finite group case they were
all closed so let's look at for example
let's pick a random two by two matrix
like this one two three five seven
and let's look at the orbit i claim the
orbit is closed
and closed in either the classical
topology if k is the real or complex
numbers
or the risky topology it's closed in
every reasonable sense right
in it's closed and it's an algebraic
variety namely it's the variety
given by two equations namely trace is
nine and determinant
is negative one all right so the variety
of these two equations
in the space of four by four matrices is
exactly the orbit so this orbit happens
to be closed
now since this is going to come up later
this week i'm sure
in this example it's actually better to
replace the determinant by an
another quadratic polynomial it's a
little bit the analog you know these are
sort of like the elementary symmetric
polynomials
and these are sort of the power sums
it's better to in this context to
replace the quote unquote elementary
symmetric polynomials by power sum so
you can replace the determinant by the
trace of x
squared trace of the matrix squared is
83.
so in general if you have these actions
you know a little theta equivalent we
saw in the previous talk it's always
traces of words and matrices that
generate
the ring of invariance now maybe all the
orbits are always closed and the
invariants always separate the orbits
right that would be the nicest thing but
not quite true right so there's
something called the null cone
hilbert called this the null kegel right
so namely what do you do you take the
variety of our ideal we had this magical
ideal
that we generated in hilbert's proof
generated by
all homogeneous and variants of positive
degree
now in the finite group case its variety
was just the origin
but in the infinite group case this
could have lots of zeros there could be
many many many points on the space we're
acting on
where all homogeneous invariants vanish
of positive degree
so what is this variety right these are
all the var all the matrices where the
trace vanishes
and the determinant vanishes and these
are the the nil potent matrices
so matrices of nil potent you know that
are no
potent cannot be separated and there's a
little linear algebra exercise you know
look at matrices like zero and then this
one this one you write down a bunch of
sort of
jordan canonical matrices and all in
different orbits and you cannot separate
them by in variance because
every invariant of positive degree takes
the value zero
okay brackets so i started
the lecture by giving you a few words
about
personal history so i should tell you
what what are these brackets
now and back to felix klein
so let's say n is d times m
and the vector space i'm acting on is
the space of
d by m matrices well our group
sld acts on this n dimensional vector
space by left multiplication right so
you have a rectangle
you look at the space of rectangular
matrices
and you act on it by left multiplication
that is a representation of the abstract
group
sld so that representation is given
to you by md times md
polynomials in d squared variables
which together form the representation
row
now the invariants are exactly the
brackets so the ring of invariance in
this case
has m choose d generators namely the d
by d minus of the rectangular d by m
matrix
that's sometimes called the first
fundamental theorem or fund of classical
invariant theory
well there's also a second fundamental
theorem that tells you the analog to the
abc relation it tells you the relations
that hold among the generators and they
are also well known there's a
well-known system of quadratic relations
known as plucker relations i'm going to
write this symbol
bracket i1 i2 up to id
for the d by d sub determinant
given by the column indices i1 up to id
in my rectangular matrix okay these are
m choose these symbols for example if d
is 2
and m is 4 there are 6 generators
bracket 1 2 1 3 1 4
two three two four three four and
there's one relation
that's the quadratic relation
now this is kind of nice you can do
geometry with this right that's what
that was client's point right whatever
you can express in these brackets should
be somewhat geometric
so suppose we have some geometric
property namely the property for six
points in the plane to lie on a conic
that's a geometric property so well
if d is three and n is six right
then our matrix x the 18
coordinates in our matrix represent
homogeneous coordinates for six
points in the plane and they lie on a
conic
if and only if this bracket monomial
equals that bracket
monomial okay so whenever you have
geometric properties involving
various shapes and projective space you
can write down
blue polynomials in the brackets that
represent those geometric facts
now the vector space that we're really
interested in that we really want to act
on
is the space of symmetric tensors or the
space of homogeneous polynomials
so i'm going to write sd k to the m
for homogeneous polynomials of degree d
in m variables that's a nice finite
dimensional vector space you know
balls in boxes many monomials generate
this
there's the formula d plus m minus one
choose m minus one that's our n and
the abstract group sld
acts on this vector space by change of
coordinates so we have a
representation row that eats
d by d matrices and makes n by n
matrices
now since the group is reductive the
invariant ring is finally generated
and the generators express geometric
properties of homogeneous polynomials
now what's the point of these
homogeneous polynomials well they cut
out hypersurfaces in the projective
space
right so so that was the motivation for
hilbert and his contemporaries they want
to know what are all the properties
that a hyper surface of degree d in a
projective
space of dimension m minus one half can
we have a finite alphabet somehow
to talk about these geometric properties
so this is the point of departure
for a more modern theory called
geometric invariant theory and i think
laurel will give a tutorial on geometric
and variant theory this afternoon
i'm going to give you sort of two
examples so the first example
is high school example so
let's say d and m are two so i'm going
to look at homogeneous polynomials of
degree two
in two variables they form a
three-dimensional vector space v
so n is three so that's the space of
binary quadrants
so it looks like this x one t to the
zero blah blah x three
t one squared so i have a three
dimensional space
with coordinates x one x two x three the
group is s
the group is s l
uh d i hope i meant it to be sld right
so i claim that
so in this example m is equal to two is
equal to d so sl2
acts on the three-dimensional space of
binary forms
oh i see i see this should be m and n
okay so there's a typo okay
this doesn't work maybe up here okay so
there's a typo okay so this should be
what are we doing s m k no
you switch m
okay yes no i wanted to i would like to
stick with sld okay
sorry guys you know confusion of indices
but i think you're going to get this
example
especially after doing the pop quiz okay
so i will follow the institute's
suggestion to take a break during a long
lecture so we're going to take a three
minute break
and in this three minute break you are
asked to write down
the three by three matrix row of g
right here and you will be have glory
forever by being the first to write this
down will take a three minute break for
you to write down a three by three
matrix
over there on the whiteboard one minute
go for it
what do you think
and that calls for a big round of
applause
any questions maybe this is a good
moment to ask for questions
comments
this is clear so luke wrote down a
representation
of the abstract group sl2
as a matrix group a group of three by
three matrices
the set of these three by three matrices
where a b
c and d are any scalars such that a
d minus b c is one that set of three by
three matrices is the group and that
group
acts and down there it's ring of
inferences
in my life i have never ever ever chosen
the basis they always came to me
okay let's go okay so in this case you
know from high school right you know the
formula for writing down the roots in
terms of the coefficients
and then the thing you take the square
root of is the discriminant
x square x 2 squared minus 4 x 1
x 3 this single polynomial
generates the ring of invariance this is
the
generator for all geometric properties
for geometric statements you can make
about two points on the line right so if
this group sort of carries the geometry
right you talk about properties of two
points on the line
and then well the interesting property
is when do two points come together one
does
when does the zero dimensional variety
subroyt in p1 becomes singular
well if and only if the discriminant
vanishes
okay let's do something slightly more
interesting
let's talk about ternary cubics
and i hope i get my d's and m's a little
better but
okay bear with me any case they're the
same again so d and m
is three so i'm interested in cubic
curves in the projective plane p2
okay so a ternary cubic
is a polynomial homogeneous of degree 3
in three unknowns t0 t1 and t2
and the coefficients x1 x2
up to x10 they are the coordinates on
the 10-dimensional vector space v we're
acting on so v
is a tender the 10-dimensional vector
space
of ternary cubics with coordinates x1 x2
up to x10
so we're interested in polynomials in
these two
in these 10 variables
and we're interested in the ring of
invariance so with a little guidance
from luke
you can write down a 10 by 10
matrix whose 100 entries
cubic polynomials in nine
unknowns and then that matrix group
has a finitely generated invariant ring
and in this case
you require two generators the two
classical
invariants that generate the ring okay
so the first invariant called s is a
quartic so this is a degree 4
homogeneous polynomial and x1 up to x10
and has 26 terms okay now that's an
important remark
right because the space of quartics in
10 variables is a big space
right it has a larger dimension but
among those
many monomials of degree 4 and x1 up to
x10
only 26 run for competition
only 26 have the right homogeneity
multi-homogeneity properties
to have a chance to appear in an
invariant and there is a unique equation
of degree 26
and this is known as the arnhold
invariant okay so this is
now what is the property well for
example people interested in tensor
decomposition
will know that the iron hold invariant
vanishes
if and only if my symmetric tensor
has tensor rank at most three okay so
typically if i take a random if i take a
rant excuse me
okay sorry yes you're right so i always
just say right
okay so tensor bordering so any case so
this is the property that's s
and then there's a another polynomial
sextic
t and it has 103 terms okay so the point
i want to make is that these are very
very very small polynomials
relative to the total number of
monomials of that degree
now just to sort of move this a tiny bit
more towards algebraic geometry right so
here's another invariant that you can
express in terms of the basic invariance
that's the discriminant right so the
discriminant delta
is a t squared minus 64
s cubed so that has degree 12 right so
2 times 6 and 3 times 4 is 12. so delta
is a homogeneous polynomial of degree
12.
still pretty small it has 2040 terms
and it vanishes if and only if the plane
cubic
has a singular point so ketan had this
picture right so
usually you know get these pictures
but if the picture is like this that
happens if and only if the polynomial
delta vanishes so that's very much a
geometric property
now if delta is not zero then this cubic
curve is a
then it's a smooth cubic curve and
that smooth cubic curve together with
the point on it is known as elliptic
curve so
the cryptography people who will be here
next summer
love elliptic curves now everybody
especially your number theorist friends
they really really like the j
invariant the j invert isn't quite an
invariant in the sense i discussed
because it's not a polynomial it's a
rational function right
that's actually better because that's a
sort of a function on projector space so
what you do is you take
s cubed this invariant you divide it by
delta
so you have the ratio of two homogeneous
polynomials of degree 12.
so this is a well-defined rational
function
on the nine-dimensional projector space
with coordinates x1 x2 up to x10
and that's called the j invariant
now the j invariant serves as a
coordinate
i'm cheating a little bit here it serves
as a coordinate on the modulized space
so a modulized space
is a quotient space of a space that is a
parameter space that parameterizes
objects so
in this case x1 up to xn is the
parameter space of all
cubic curves in the plane but then if we
take
cubic curves modulo projective
transformations
we get the proj of this graded ring
the invariant ring so we have this
graded ring where s and t
have degree 4 and 6 respectively and j
is sort of a nice coordinate on that
space
but more about geometric invariant
theory at 2 p.m
today in laurel's lecture
let me come back to the picture so this
talk had exactly one proof
and also had exactly one picture let me
explain the picture
there's a very old theorem in
geometry known as the kd bacharach
theorem
that says the following thing about nine
points in the plane
suppose you have eight points in the
plane p1 up to p8 and these are the
white points so we have eight points
this one this one this one this one this
one eight
white points in the plane
then there's a unique ninth point
indicated by the arrow
with the property that every cubic curve
through the eight points
must pass also through the ninth point
very nice theorem so you know
i mean suppose you start with the two
cubic equations maybe the
the red equation and the the blue
equation right by bezeus theorem they
have nine common solutions
right well then you can
replace either blue or red by any linear
combination
and you still you know have i'm sorry so
say this again you take any other cubic
that also goes to the eight points it
must necessarily go
through the ninth point okay this is a
very old easy theorem it's actually very
fundamental
in the current interest work of greg
bleckemann in particular
on the connection between semi-definite
programming and semi-definite
programming and polynomial optimization
so there are two people in our program
or maybe at least two people greg and
pablo parillo
who connect our program to the
concurrent program
the concurrent program has a workshop
next week
on issues related to semi-definite
programming
and that sort of plays a certain role in
this topic
now this is old there's something new so
i wrote a paper with the jurgen viktor
gabot from munich and chun chang ren
recently which we submitted to the math
monthly
and we solved the riddle that been
around for a little while what's a good
way of writing
p9 in terms of p1 up to p8 right so
by the statement you can argue that
there is a rational function
now there's a rational expression for
the ninth point in terms of
the eight given points and uh there's an
explicit
formula in terms of brackets brackets so
these are the brackets
oops what happened
brackets like this one so there's you
know a bunch of expressions like this
that give you the coordinates for the
ninth point in terms of the eight points
okay any questions so i think i have
16 minutes left so i will be done well
before the end of my time any questions
not too bad it's a short paper you know
it's very i mean we write the formula
okay um let me talk about finite
generation
so we saw that for a finite matrix group
the invariant ring is always finally
generated i gave you
the proof and if you have a reductive
group
for example sld if you knew how to
realize the reynolds operator for sld i
also give you
gave you a proof an algorithm for for
finding generators for sld
so the question was what about arbitrary
matrix group suppose you have an
arbitrary group g of n by n matrices
is the ring of invariance always finally
generated right does hilbot's
theorem from 1890 extend to
non-reductive groups
now why is this a meaningful question
right so if you maybe
saw the proof you said well what's the
point right the ideals are always you
can form the same idea or you could look
at the ideal of all homogeneous and
variants of positive it's still finally
generated
right and maybe its generators
symmetrized still generate the range of
the variance
well that would be true except you can't
symmetrize right non-reductive means you
cannot symmetrize that's the whole point
of not being reductive okay
now also we will not talk about ideals
we're talking about
k sub algebras right a sub algebra
polynomial ring need not be finally
generated so for example if you have a
polynomial ring and two variables x
and y and look at the you know x x
y x y squared so they generate a sub
algebra and that's not in the theory
right that's it you need them all
that's not a finely generated sub ring
so what about so this was one of the
open prompts stated by hilbert
in the uh 1900 in the national congress
and if students at berkeley are
unfortunate enough to have me
in their german language exam they
either get fedex clients ellen or pogba
or they get to pick one of the hillbill
problems to translate
okay so a negative answer was given 60
years later
by nagata in 1959
and so there is the r groups matrix
groups where the ring of invariant is
not finally generated so what i like to
do
in the remaining time i like to describe
a version
of nagata's counter example and
the exposition i'm going to give is some
notation is coming from this paper soggy
base of cox nagata rings
okay so we'll give you an example now a
matrix group
whose invariant ring is not finally
generated and then the talk is over
okay so that's the plan for the
remaining time
good structure for all non-reductive
groups for the generator
is gone okay he's giving a talk at one
o'clock jan will speak in the
combinatoric seminar
um well they tend to i think the answer
is yes
do you know so there's a i mean they're
essentially additive groups so
multiplicative
you know if you take k star versions
like k star
they are reductive but if you take
additive groups
um they tend to be not reductive i can't
answer the top of that right so there's
maybe experts over there
well the question was is there a
structure theory for non-reductive
groups
can we classify non-reductive groups
okay let's look at one example so we
haven't so let's
there's always something new at the
bottom as you said the unique product is
a composition series of additive fields
so the additive groups are at the heart
of it okay guys let's see an additive
group
okay so let's do the form so m
n the space i'm acting on is an even
integer so n is 2 times
m an even integer and let me start with
the additive group of the m dimensional
vector space i'm going to take
k to the m so that's a vector space and
by vector addition
that's a group so let's start with that
group
okay i want to pass to a sub in a moment
now that group has a
representation in terms of 2m by 2m
matrices as follows very simple and it's
going to act on a polynomial ring and
two m variables x one up to x m y one
up to y m as follows it does nothing on
the axis
okay it fixes the x variables
but it takes the y variables and it
shifts them as follows so
y i gets mapped to y i
plus u i x i and u
i is the i coordinate of the group
element u
right so you give me you know a group
element which is a vector u
and then so your u you know
i can write as a 2 m by 2 m matrix
and then that's what it does right it's
sort of very looks like an identity
matrix with a little bit of
stuff above the diagonal very harmless
looking action now i'm going to
twist this as follows i'm going to fix
an integer d
less than m and i pick a random d
by m matrix u okay so random means
well whatever random outside is a risky
closed set so i pick a random d by m
matrix
and g is the row space so g
is a d dimensional vector subspace of k
to the m
still a group right so so the group i'm
going to use
is the subspace spanned by the rows of u
so as an as an abstract group that's k
to the d
right the additive group k to the d but
i'm going to use it you know
comes from a matrix u
okay so that's an abstract group this is
k to the d
and it acts on the polynomial ring and
two m variables by the same rule right
so i just keep the action
that's my example exactly
so that's it's very clear right so i
take kd
all i need is the matrix u and you can
write down with a little help from you
from luke right and 2m by 2m matrix
whose entries you know
depend on big u and little u
okay so let's see an example oops
take the punch line away so how could
you make invariance well you could do
the following trick
you take the matrix u and you add one
more row
you add the row y one divided by x one
y two divide by x two and so on and then
you clear denominators
you multiply on the left with the
diagonal matrix
x1 up to xm okay so
so this is now a matrix
of size d plus 1 times
m and it has linear entries right in the
first
d rows it has linear entries and the x's
and in the last row you just have y one
up to y oh maybe there's a typo sorry
guys
this is a ym divided by xm okay
so i take y i divide by x i and this
just clears the denominators it
multiplies the i
column by by x i okay
so if the parameters are very small
so if the parameters are very small so
for example if
m minus d is two then they generate
so these invariants so the the maximum
minus okay so what are the invariants so
first of all we have x1 up to x m right
they are invariant
right that's everybody saw that right x
1 up to x
and my invariant and i also claim that
the maximal minus the d
plus 1 times d plus 1 minus of this
matrix are invariant
and that's by the rule but you have a
determinant it doesn't change if you add
a row
you know to another row right so if you
take one of the early rows and you add
it to y one up to
m row the determinant doesn't change and
that just says it's an invariant okay
so if the parameters are really really
small then these and then
since they look puzzled is it clear no
it's clear
yeah so so for small parameters they
actually generate okay these are
variants generate
but i claim in general they do not so i
claim the ring of invariance is not
finally generated if the following holds
for example if m is d plus 3
and m is at least nine okay so if the
difference
m minus t if the co dimension of u
is three and the ambient dimension is
nine
then this is not a finally generated
ring okay that's the example
i think you don't need characteristic
zero
yeah well you have to be a little bit
careful what we mean by generic so
um you certainly don't need
characteristics zero but maybe you want
to avoid small
characteristics too let me put the the
proof the proof
idea and then we'll just maybe georgio
knows i don't know about the
pets or surfaces of the two element
field okay i don't know okay so
maybe characteristic two and three is
bad but
it's the same example but yeah okay
that's the example so this
so this is a variation on the theme of
mukai
okay so here's the proof okay what you
do is you blow up
points in the plane so p2 comes
from the three okay and
what's you well u really specifies
m points in the plane so u is a six
by nine matrix okay
so that six by nine matrix its row
vectors
are perpendicular to a three by nine
matrix
and the columns of this three by nine
matrix are the homogeneous coordinates
of nine
points in the plane nine random points
in the plane
so the rows of u that's a gale
transformer
the gale dual of nine points in the
plane the linear relations
among the nine vectors representing nine
points in the plane
well if you blow these nine points up
and you do some classical geometry
the surface you get has very very many
symmetries
okay well first of all it has the
symmetries
sm the symmetric group of m letters acts
on this
surface right because you blow up these
points and they're you know it doesn't
matter how you label them
so this whole situation is certainly
symmetric
under the relabeling of the points but
that's not enough there's
more symmetry you can attach a little
hook
to the drinking diagram and you pass to
a larger vial group
and these are the viral groups d5 e6 e7
e8 e9 e10 e11 and so on so in each of
these cases
you have a vial group that's given by
you know picture like this quiver maybe
something like this but if you just have
this row you have the symmetric group
but you add you know
one little thing down here that one
little thing that extra generators
called a cremona transformation so that
extra generator
the cremona generator that is a
beautiful thing
and you will discover these viral groups
now what about these valley groups well
these vinyl groups they are given by
generators and relations so these are
groups that are presented by generators
and relation and this is the picture
this picture is a system of generators
and relations
now if you have a group that's given by
generators and relations this group may
be finite or infinite
right and it so happens that it's finite
up to eight and it's infinite from nylon
and that fact that the group is infinite
translates into the fact
that you cannot get away with finitely
many generators
i promised that i'll be done ahead of
time so here's the conclusion slide
so i talked about some very very old
classical invariant theory i think it's
a fun subject it's timeless
and experts in this workshop will decide
whether it's relevant
and maybe uh in google books thinks that
i'm a co-author
of hilbert now i
started by talking about something that
happened in 1984
and to the young people here that was
before you were born that was probably
maybe you thought that klein and hilber
and i were contemporaries that's not
true
okay so i'm not a co-author so reinhard
laubenbach and i
so right now i translated this and i
wrote an introduction so this is a
lectures
and zomo semester 1897. gerting and
professor hilbert
gave a course on the theory of algebraic
and variance
and that's the book thanks for your
attention
i think we have time for discussion
questions questions so in what sense
does that extra note of chroma
transform i mean i'm not sure what
you're meaning uh so this gives you
maybe let georgia answer let's make this
more interactive where's georgio
georgio this is georgio ottaviani and he
will tell us about the cremona
action yeah so what you can do
so if you have a configuration of say
eight points let's make six points
that's everybody's favorite cubic
surface right so
suppose you have six points in the plane
labeled one two
three up to six so what can you do first
you can you know change the labels
right that's one thing you can do but
here's another thing you can do you can
pick
three of the six points and call them
the coordinate points
so i made a choice right
so the first point is one zero zero the
second point is zero one zero and the
last point is zero zero one okay
so then you take the cremona map which
is called reciprocalize the coordinates
right so you take the coordinates x
y z and you map them to one over x
one over y one over z okay that's a nice
map
outside so my three points span a
triangle they span
three lines and that's a very nice
one-to-one well-defined map
outside that triangle of lines but on
that triangle of lines is a bit weird so
what it does it maps the three lines to
three points and it blows up
the three points two lines right so
the picture that you would see in a
textbook looks
something like this you know so here is
my six
points one two three four
five six so maybe i pick these
and then you know the image of this
transformation so two four and five they
have perfectly nice images over there
but then you know the lines become
points and the points become lines so i
get maybe 1 prime
3 prime 6 prime and now i have a new
labeled configuration of 6 points in the
plane
so that additional symmetry acts on
objects attached to my blown-up surface
such as homology ring
ox ring all these
thanks again
right